给到场支持的领导们
嗨大家好
刚看完片段
我是不是要强吻
你可不要过去
曾主演七部戏剧的王心凌
邀请合作过的其中五位男主角来当嘉宾
不但是个大惊喜
而且还很经典
与低位先生的名道相隔多年再同台
尤其这首在荆州舞狮被票选为最洗脑的经典
戏剧神曲
花了袈裟
旋律一出
所以画面立刻浮现脑海中
再次带大家回到过去
♪ 爱是花儿的芬芳 ♪
♪ 是蝴蝶的翅膀 ♪
♪ 是伤心的故作品 ♪
♪ 你是他的管家 ♪
♪ 爱在孤独中绝望 ♪
♪ 在绝望中坚强 ♪
♪ 今朝不继续不停 ♪
这很大英雄
♪ 睡在我怀里 ♪
♪ 好迷人的细节 ♪
♪ 我不能直直的地方 ♪
♪ 都有你温柔的手 ♪
♪ 逞强的包围 ♪
♪ 就算重来一次 ♪
♪ 还是会抓人光 ♪
♪ 收 ♪
♪ 那岁月梦泪 ♪
♪ 极致的地方都有你善意的谎言 ♪
♪ 让我心碎 ♪
♪ 直到随风而天 ♪
♪ 才看见从未到过的地方 ♪
啊啊啊谢谢谢谢季
最新合作对象坤达后
接着登场的张栋梁又勾起粉丝不少回忆
让人忍不住跟着哼唱
而且会发现男主角们还各自带的小道具惊喜哦
19年年
他笑着回答
这不是双
啊啊
♪ and easy to fall ♪
and easy
♪ and easy ♪
♪ we can ♪
♪ 天上地下没有什么糖果 ♪
♪ 天空是绵绵的糖 ♪
♪ 就算塌下来又怎样 ♪
♪ 雨下再大 ♪
♪ 又别再白送给每一场 ♪
♪ 希望你明白你微笑与爱心流动 ♪
♪ 远光爱情也好 ♪
都在期待
让人心和浪漫
♪ 我喜欢梦中却想着起来笑 ♪
♪ 也要让你看到最后一丝的骄傲 ♪
♪ 因为你说错了错 ♪
♪ 他你的气泡的笑才有男人的味道 ♪
♪ 可能是不知道没有你的日子会有多了解 ♪
♪ 秋风是我杀的歌 ♪
♪ 像谁知道真的道歉 ♪
♪ 只要能够对你好 ♪
♪ 我都会做到 ♪
王心凌边环绕小菊的边与灵宝们互动着
而排除万难来站台的五位护花使者难得合体
成了心灵专属
一日限定的男神组合
这一刻相信又在缔造了一个经典
这个绕一圈的故事告诉我们是什么
旧情人还是比较好
因为西街真的是最久的了
在这个里面西街是最久的
对对对
然后再来几次就是诶我我我再来是我
然后这样应该动作栋梁栋梁
我坤达是最后
对不对
所以这是有兄弟之后还不叫一声大哥
实在是
不过今天真的很开心哦
就是你看心理面积多大没有
我真的很很很谢谢大家特地回来
然后有的还是飞来的
真的很谢谢好朋友们都这么支持我的
这场演唱会都义不容辞
其实我也一直期待今天这场演唱会期待好久
因为好早好早之前就已经接到通知
说有没有可能一起来演唱会唱煎熬这首歌对
那因为我考虑很久
是因为这是因为金毛这首歌对我来讲
真的是因为最近单身吗
这么这么快就到正题了
你戳到了我相通的地方
没有啊
好的开始啊好的
不过ok的
因为看到你就开心了
真的但我跟你讲
现在我们有一件很重要的事要做
是是要大合照的意思
我们来至少还有一张真的有
准备好要手机
让我下去换一换啊
你也有啊
哎呀先先看下
哈哈哎不好意思
大家不好意思
不好意思
当自己家哈
那个倒水的倒水哈
好棒哦
可以可以可以可以可以来123